from wonder into wonder existence opens
the best fighter is never angry
knowledge is a treasure but practice is
the key to it
to a mind that is still the whole
universe surrenders
those who know do not speak
those who speak do not know
to understand the limitation of things
desire them
[Music]
be still
stillness reveals the secrets of
eternity
respond intelligently even to
unintelligent treatment
because of a great love one is
courageous
[Music]
an over sharpened sword cannot last long
when you accept yourself the whole world
accepts you
sincere words are not fine fine words
are not sincere
the way of heaven is to help and not
harm
music in the soul can be heard by the
universe
he who talks more is sooner exhausted
as soon as you have made a thought laugh
at it
a bad man is a good man's job
take care with the end as you do at the
beginning
the further one goes the less one
knows when goodness is lost there is
morality
to hold you must first open your hand
let go
spring comes and the grass grows by
itself
our enemies are not demons but human
beings like ourselves
when you are at one with loss the loss
is experienced willingly
[Music]
composure is the ruler of instability
with few there is attainment with much
there is confusion
[Music]
he who knows that enough is enough will
always have enough
there is no greater danger than
underestimating your opponent
[Music]
do your work then step back
the only path to serenity
if you are untrustworthy people will not
trust you
a good traveler has no fixed plans and
is not intent on arriving
[Music]
stop thinking and end your problems
if you are depressed you are living in
the past
if you are anxious you are living in the
future if you are at peace you are
living in the present
when there is no desire all things are
at peace
he who obtains has little he who
scatters has much
if you want to lead them you must place
yourself behind them
give evil nothing to oppose and it will
disappear by itself
those who flow as life flows know they
need no other force
he who acts spoils he who grasps lets
slip
if you wish to be out front then act as
if you were behind
[Music]
love is a decision not an emotion
go to the people
live with them learn from them love them
if you do not value rare treasures you
will stop others from stealing
a scholar who cherishes the love of
comfort is not fit to be deemed a
scholar
a man with outward courage tears to die
a man with inner courage dares to live
one who is too insistent on his own
views finds few to agree with him
there is a time to live and a time to
die but never to reject the moment
if you do not change direction you may
end up where you are heading
the more laws and order are made
prominent the more thieves and robbers
there will be
if you try to change it you will ruin it
try to hold it and you will lose it
time is a created thing
to say i don't have time is like saying
i don't want to
[Music]
to attain knowledge add things every day
to attain wisdom remove things every day
[Music]
care about what other people think and
you will always be their prisoner
the tao is nowhere to be found
yet it nourishes and completes all
things
manifest plainness embrace simplicity
reduce selfishness have few desires
do you have the patience to wait until
your mud settles and the water is clear
when wealth and honors lead to arrogancy
this brings its evil on itself
governing a great nation is like cooking
a small fish too much handling will
spoil it
[Music]
not seeking not expecting she is present
and can welcome all things
just remain in the center watching and
then forget that you are there
[Music]
he who defends with love will be secure
heaven will save him and protect him
with love
if the people must be ever fearful of
death then there will always be an
executioner
when pure sincerity forms within it is
outwardly realized in other people's
hearts
at the center of your being you have the
answer you know who you are and you know
what you want
when men lost their understanding of the
tao intelligence came along bringing
hypocrisy with it
[Music]
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength while loving someone deeply
gives you courage
[Music]
i have just three things to teach
simplicity patience compassion these
three are your greatest treasures
kindness in words creates confidence
kindness and thinking creates
profoundness kindness and giving creates
love
your own positive future begins in this
moment all you have is right now every
goal is possible from here
if lightning is the anger of the gods
then the guides are concerned mostly
about trees
health is the greatest possession
contentment is the greatest treasure
confidence is the greatest friend
a violent wind does not last for a whole
morning a sudden rain does not last for
the whole day
there is no disaster greater than not
being content there is no misfortune
greater than being covetous
[Music]
the wise man is square but not sharp
honest but not not malign straight but
not severe bright but not dazzling
stop leaving and you will arrive
stop searching and you will see
stop running away and you will be found
fill your bowl to the brim and it will
spill keep sharpening your knife and it
will blunt
if i had just a little bit of wisdom i
should walk the great path and fear only
straying from it
to realize that you do not understand is
a virtue not to realize that you do not
understand is a defect
ambition has one heel nailed in well
though she stretches her fingers to
touch the heavens
when you are content to be simply
yourself and don't compare or compete
everyone will respect you
the difficult problems in life always
start off being simple
great affairs always start off being
small
the snow goose need not bathe to make
itself white
neither need you do anything but be
yourself
love is of all the passions the
strongest for it attacks simultaneously
the head the heart and the senses
when the student is ready the teacher
will appear when the student is truly
ready the teacher will disappear
hope and fear are both phantoms that
arise from thinking of the self when we
don't see the self as self what do we
have to fear
water is the softest thing yet it can
penetrate mountains and earth
this shows clearly the principle of
softness overcoming hardness
you are controlled by the one who makes
you angry
[Music]
the reason why the universe is eternal
is that it does not live for itself it
gives life to others as it transforms
[Music]
ordinary men hate solitude but the
master makes use of it embracing his
aloneness realizing he is one with the
whole universe
do you imagine the universe is agitated
go into the desert at night and look at
the stars
this practice should answer the question
[Music]
the softest things in the world overcome
the hardest things in the world
through this i know the advantage of
taking no action
to bear and not to own to act and not
lay claim to do the work and let it go
for just letting it go is what makes it
stay
[Music]
knowing others is intelligence knowing
yourself is true wisdom
mastering others is strength mastering
yourself is true power
[Music]
you